bonjour henri sterdyniak merci de
répondre à nos questions sur arte france
462 milliards d'euros cette année et
maintenant donc le plan de relance dont
42 des 100 milliards seront dépensés
avant 2021
dès qu'il s'est vite pour avoir un
impact rapide selon la sémantique un
tout à l'heure de de bruno le maire
c'est quoi c'est dépenser plus pour
relancer plus on est toujours dans le
quoi qu'il en coûte un budget pour je
cite pour bruno le maire pour répondre à
l'urgence et préparer l'avenir
oui bien sûr on est dans cette situation
le gouvernement a décidé d'avoir un
bouquet extrêmement expansionniste avec
un déficit public de l'ordre de 10%
cette année de 7 % sans doute l'année
prochaine ou plus du tout dans une idée
des politiques d'austérité qui ont suivi
la crise financière l'a vraiment on va
essayer de dépenser au maximum pour
soutenir l'activité
venez de parler du déficit déficit de
l'état va atteindre 195 milliards à la
fin de l'année 152 milliards fin 2021
un retour à l'équilibré est possible et
si oui qu on sort c'est pas une question
qui se pose aujourd'hui un produit on
accepte des déficits publics importants
d'une parce que l'activité a fortement
baissé d'autre part pour soutenir les
entreprises sans doute aussi un peu pour
soutenir les ménages
le chômage partiel est donc le retour à
l'équilibré qui sont sa star 2024 2025
si un jour ni eau ni rond dont on y
parvient c'est plus c'est plus la
priorité à la priorité aujourd'hui pour
gouvernement c'est d'un côté de soutenir
les entreprises en difficulté et de
l'autre de préparer l'avenir avec un
plan de relance dans lequel il ya une
forte composante écologique et pour
petit ific
qu'est-ce qu'il vous évoque vous ce
budget 2021 crise et moi qu'est ce qui
vous évoque ce budget de 2021 il évoque
surtout le fait qu'effectivement c'est
dire c'est un keynésien
c'est à dire budget dans lequel on
estime de ce qui compte c'est surtout
surtout de l'activité avec bien sûr un
soutien très fort aux entreprises
on sait pas encore de quoi sera fait
l'année 2009 21
il est fort possible que le déficit soit
encore plus élevé si effectivement il
faut soutenir un certain nombre
d'entreprises s'il faut maintenir plus
longtemps
le dispositif de chômage partiel ce qui
manque dans le budget c'est le soutien
aux ménages en difficulté les plus
précaires en particulier les étudiants
les les travailleurs qui ont des
contrats courts ou les chaluts le plan
de relance sera financée par la
croissance le gouvernement est il
réaliste optimiste patrick laure de
relance financés par l'empa sur sur les
marchés financiers éventuellement par le
soutien que nous apportera la bce et
union européenne qui elle aussi va se
financer sur les marchés financiers la
croissance on verra plus tard on verra
dans cinq ans je problème et c'est
aujourd'hui on a on a besoin de faire
des dépenses et donc on va recourir aux
marchés financiers les marchés
financiers vont nous prêter à des taux
qui sont aujourd'hui pratiquement zéro
des fois même négatif donc c c'est là
dessus que on peut compter mais la
confiance des ménages et des entreprises
dans cette période sanitaire difficile
parce que ce n'est pas un frein
justement temps rapport à ce budget 2021
faut distinguer les ménages des
entreprises sont inquiets en raison de
la crise sanitaire on sait pas quand
l'épidémie va se terminer c'est là la
grande incertitude
par contre les entreprises peuvent
compter sur l'aide de l'état qui
prolonger les prêts garantis qui sans
doute pas accepté de ne pas réclamer des
cotisants
sion et des impôts en retard le problème
c'est là c'est la crise sanitaire
le gouvernement lui ni fait ce qu'il
peut et d'autres n'y a aucune raison
d'avoir des doutes sur la solidité des
finances publiques sur la dette publique
de toute évidence on va pas en dehors du
gouvernement ne va pas augmenter par
rapport
pas de hausse d'impôts donc selon bruno
le maire qui l'a redit aujourd'hui j'en
veux dire vraiment et comment le
gouvernement continue les baisses
d'impôt c'est pas ce qui fait de plus
génial parce que va réduire la taxe
d'habitation sur les plus riches qui est
pas génial parce que ça déséquilibrer
les finances communales il va réduire la
peau sa production
là aussi au détriment des finances rue
calme et on aurait préféré des mesures
plus ciblées sur les entreprises qui
s'engagent dans la transition l'écologie
il va continuer la baisse de l'impôt sur
les sociétés là aussi sans distinguer
les entreprises qui en ont vraiment
besoin
donc il ya effectivement un peu gaspille
alcan dans dans ces baisses d'impôts le
message quand même que donne le
gouvernement sait que à court terme aura
pas de hausses massives d'impôts pour
combler le déficit public
et ça c'est un message qu'il faut
qu'elle est chaud plus ou moins
confiance merci henri sterdyniak d'avoir
répondu à une question je rappelle que
vous êtes économiste membre des
économistes atterrés